From heists-within-heists to shocking
betrayals, we're here to untangle
this series' many complex knots. This is the
ending of "Kaleidoscope" Season 1, explained.
Episodes of Netflix's dazzling heist drama
"Kaleidoscope" can be viewed in any order,
apart from "White," which should always be watched
last. While the show's non-linear format initially
seems like just a cool gimmick, it soon reveals
itself to be an elegant feat of storytelling.
Luckily, "Kaleidoscope" isn't likely
to be "one last job" for its makers,
and it's certainly far from their first.
Show creator Eric Garcia wrote the novel
"Matchstick Men," which was adapted into
the 2003 movie of the same name. That film
was directed by Ridley Scott, who serves as an
executive producer on "Kaleidoscope." Notably,
"Matchstick Men," which stars Nicolas Cage and
Alison Lohman as a father-daughter con artist duo,
plays tricks on its characters and the
audience, to entertaining and emotional
effect. Obviously, this is more than a
little reminiscent of "Kaleidoscope."
Garcia and Scott aren't the only intriguing
figures involved in "Kaleidoscope." Leading man
Ray Vernon is fantastically played by Giancarlo
Esposito. As elegant criminal mastermind Gus Fring
on "Better Call Saul" and "Breaking Bad," he works
hard to protect a super-secure underground lair,
rather than breach one. On the opposite end
of the show's call sheet is Max Casella,
who stars in the "Pink" episode as small-time
crook and big-time podcast therapy fan Taco,
who steals just about every scene he's in.
Stan Loomis, played by Peter Mark Kendall, is
a smuggler who loves the finer things in life
and lacks a taste for personal growth or even
basic heist hygiene. More than once, Stan's
distractible, dreamy nature leads to ruin for the
crew. Most notably, he leaves his hipster glasses
at the scene of the crime and makes a getaway
in a car with easily traceable vanity plates.
Though he's one of the least
violent members of the crew,
Stan indirectly spills his share of blood.
Carlos takes out Stan's mother and wife,
and Stan dodges the feds when they take down
Bob. By the end of "Kaleidoscope," Stan has also
butchered any chance he once had to learn from
his mistakes. Still, he lives to try another day,
and stuff his face with tacos when he realizes
Judy has likely taken the money and run.
A bent lawyer who moonlights as a fence, Ava
Mercer is Agent Nazan Abbasi's white whale.
To protect Ray after he escapes from prison, Ava
notifies the FBI that Nazan is using drugs on the
job. This costs Nazan custody of her kid and
kickstarts her quest for revenge against Ava.
Nazan's obsession with Ava and Ray comes to a
fatal head in "Pink" and dead-ends in "White."
Ava's motives aren't always entirely
clear outside of her fondness for Ray,
her grandmother, and the high life.
Meanwhile, Nazan's obsession with
tying Ava and Ray to the Diamond Way heist and
the SLS job is simple. The lady wants revenge.
Ultimately, Nazan gets a version of this,
as Ava is killed in a shoot-out after a
bitter fight for her life. But Nazan doesn't
live long enough to enjoy it. As Roger warns
Hannah in "Yellow," the Triplets take Nazan
down by sending a lackey to take her out in
the street. She dies a few steps later.
This is just another way "Kaleidoscope"
drives home the idea that chasing white
whales only leads to death by drowning.
Bob and Judy Goodwin's story shows how
hard it is to escape a toxic romance and
a life of crime. Essentially, Bob is
fire, Judy is gasoline, and together,
they burn down any trust left among the crew on
the night of the heist. This comes to a head when
Bob attempts to steal the full seven billion
for them and take out the rest of the team.
“You did the right thing, okay?”
While Judy appears to end her relationship with
Bob in "White" by seemingly killing him to save
Stan, we see her heart still belongs to him in
"Pink." "Kaleidoscope" knows old habits don't just
die hard, they die twice. Bob meets an end that
awaits so many fueled by jealousy, one he could
have avoided by going to therapy before he's set
on a one-way path to bleeding out on the beach.
Though RJ is great with mechanics and music, the
crew's getaway driver doesn't have much to do,
aside from making the occasional
funny comment and shooting Bob
in the buttock. Despite having a sweet,
winning energy, RJ still loses big time.
Crime isn't in RJ's nature, but he fights
to prove himself to Ray and the crew. One
of the central questions "Kaleidoscope"
asks is whether anyone can really change,
and if it's worth it. RJ changes from a
fairly good dude to a hardened criminal
by drawing a gun on Bob. However, he can't
quite make the tough guy transition stick,
especially since RJ's trying to protect Judy,
who kills him to protect Bob. Ultimately,
he's just too good for the heist
game, and way too bad at playing it.
On a happier note, Hannah's sister Liz survives
the emotional ending of "Kaleidoscope." Like RJ,
we don't know much about Liz, but we
know she's comfortable enough with
crime to manage to keep her nose clean.
However, RJ might have gotten off easy if
Liz traded her life of leisure for a life of
helping Hannah manage the Triplets' wealth.
With cheekbones that good, Roger has got to
be bad. Most episodes portray Roger as the
well-heeled and respected creator of the world's
safest safe, but that couldn't be further from the
truth. Roger is the latest long con pulled
by Ray Vernon's former partner in crime,
Graham Davies. If Ray's story explores how
poisonous a life fueled by revenge can be,
Roger's is a cautionary tale confirming there's
no rest for the wicked. Though Roger enjoys the
high life, he's always looking over his shoulder,
even before Leo and his crew arrive on the scene.
Roger admits to Ray that he isn't sure he could've
saved Lily. He tells Hannah that loyalty means
nothing to him. But there's something bittersweet
in just how much he protests against connection,
while also blatantly seeking it. But as his wife
leaves him and he loses his son to what may one
day be a murder charge, it's easy to see his
treasure for what it is, and that's fools' gold.
Hannah is Ray's daughter and Leo's
greatest protégé. She's warm, intelligent,
and inscrutable when it comes to where her
allegiance lies. Until "Pink," that is, when
she reveals to her father that she took the take
and switched the bearer bonds with copy paper.
Cynics will say Hannah plays her dad to save
her own neck from the Triplets. However,
her heartfelt admission to Ray makes it clear that
she pulls the con to save her dad from himself.
By switching the bonds out before the crew can
make off with them, she protects the evil trio's
fortune and buys back her dad's safety. She also
manages to purchase a super-sweet mansion to live
in with her baby and Ava's dogs. Hannah breaks
the family cycle of self-sabotage, bonds with her
estranged dad, and seems to be the only member of
the "Kaleidoscope" heist crew to come out on top.
"I’m not your sweetpea, and
I’m not your inside man.”
It all seems peachy until you consider the
international bad guys who now run Hannah's life,
and the fact that her dad is likely murdered
by Roger's kid. If these sobering realities
don't take the sweetness out of that
seaside mansion, we don't know what will.
The side criminals of "Kaleidoscope" aren't
exactly gentlemen thieves like Ray, but they are
horrifying, haughty, and hilarious. Plus, they
all meet absolutely awful ends that illustrate
a key "Kaleidoscope" theme. Basically, if you do
crime long enough, you'll definitely take a fall.
Carlos is Roger's right-hand
man, ready to throw hands and
guns whenever the need arises. Though this
hitman picks off his fair share of lives,
he meets his bitter end in "Red." Then
there's Andrew, a former employee of
Roger's who is framed by Hannah and engages in
his own crimes of extortion after Roger fires
him. "Kaleidoscope" demonstrates that greed is
definitely not good many times over, especially
when cocky Andrew overplays his hand and gets
a plastic bag to the head for his trouble.
Perhaps the most memorable side criminals of
all are the therapy podcast-loving Taco and
cardigan-rocking Samson. This dynamic duo
provides a brief but potent shot of belly
laughter alongside their bloodshed
during their brief time on screen.
"Kaleidoscope" is about cycles, whether it's
the turn of the screw, the tumble of locks,
or the spin of the titular kaleidoscope.
These characters circle the truth of
themselves through each choice they make,
then endure the full-circle consequences,
and occasionally, the benefits. At the center
of these overlapping cycles is Ray Vernon,
alias Leo Pap. Cycles are nearly impossible to
break, and Ray is the foremost symbol of this
theme. Many episodes are framed by his attempts
to express to Hannah why he's done what he's done,
and why so much of it is motivated by his
desire to change, or at least to redeem himself.
It's never been about the money for Ray. Instead,
it's about revenge, which he gets at a grave cost.
When the one silver lining of your perfect heist
is that your daughter heisted it out from under
you to save your life, it's a sign that times
are hard. Ray loses a lot over the course of
"Kaleidoscope," from the bonds to his crew to Ava,
and ultimately his own life. Yet he still wins.
He may be driven to exact revenge on Roger for not
saving Lily, a revenge he achieves by stashing the
club jewels in Roger's private vault. But his true
bounty is Hannah's forgiveness and acceptance.
As the crew sails away from Manhattan and
into a bleak future in "Red," Ray says,
"No one can pinpoint the exact
moment it all fell apart."
The heist goes off perfectly, but
afterward, everything goes sideways. Indeed,
"Kaleidoscope" gives its crew plenty
of opportunities to suffer and shine.
Seeing our master criminals at their best
and worst creates an intriguing energy.
As creator Eric Garcia told The New York Post,
he drew influence from many classic movies,
including "Rififi" and "Pulp Fiction."
Like "Rififi," "White" showcases a
largely nonverbal and very intricate
heist sequence. The first line spoken
comes when Stan speaks after
several complex steps, saying,
"Well that was easy."
"Kaleidoscope" also delivers its own
contributions to the heist hall of fame,
including Judy's press-on nail/sim
card hand-off and the sweetly comic
distraction of dosing the prison mess with
magic mushrooms. Best of all is the moment
when Hannah heists her dad in a neat and
well-intentioned double cross he doesn't
anticipate. The show doesn't indicate this
until the very last moment, which turns
feelings of deception into the pure delight
of seeing an excellent magic trick pulled off.
“We may have made a little change to the plan.”
Obsession, revenge, trust, and family loyalty fuel
the series and pack it to the brim with emotional
heat. The biggest weapon in its arsenal is a
double-barreled shotgun of revenge and regret.
Because of the kaleidoscope nature of the show's
storytelling, we get to see its many characters
shift throughout time. They change dramatically,
creating a vivid portrait of their motivations.
Maintaining entertainment and emotional
resonance at the same time is hard to
pull off. It's an even neater trick to
balance these two forces while creating a
show that can reportedly be watched more
than 5,000 different ways. In a sense,
pulling this off is pulling off a magnificent
heist while telling a story about heists. If a
big, splashy, heist-centric TV show can deftly
tackle destructive cycles, unspeakable trauma,
and the difficult healing process, there
may be hope for streaming media yet.